Um, three, you look great.
A viral New York Times article featured
36 questions that could supposedly make
any two people fall in love.
We wanted to see what would happen if
we ask these questions to two complete
strangers on a blind date.
My name is Michael Joe.
Just turned 25, um, two weeks ago.
Pretty good. I'm feeling that
kind of existential dread,
um, quarter life crisis. I'm
kind of ready for something new.
Something less brief.
Hello. Hi. Hi Michael. It's
such a dramatic entrance.
My name is Andrew Morrison.
I have my own film production company.
I work with clients in the
travel industry. Thank you.
I just came from work.
This isn't like your everyday wear.
This is pretty much like what I wear to
work. So really a good fit. Good. Taylor.
Thank you. Thank you. Like I'm
not as, I wish I were. Yeah,
let's pour this
and
I don't think it's ready,
but I'm thirsty. The little
chairs, I guess you
don't do that with tape,
but I like your style.
Okay.
What do you do? Um, you want to
know that first? It's really random.
I buy rocks.
Things like kitchens,
like countertops or like hamburger.
Yeah, sure. Kind of like that. Yeah.
Take four minutes and tell your partner
your life story in as much detail as
possible.
You don't want to go first.
You go put the pressure on me.
I want to get to know you.
Okay.
Kirpan Seritos most of
my family lived in La.
I worked in fashion for a bit about four
years and it was on the manufacturing
side. I came to really
resent it. Really? Yeah.
Because every negative image about like
the fashion industry is pretty true.
You know, that's how I found myself
buying rocks, I guess. Who Am about you?
Okay. Um, I am from a town
called Scandia in Minnesota.
I grew up on a farm there.
I wanted to leave a lot earlier.
I had been traveling the
world a lot with my father.
I would say what really kind of marked
and impacted my youth was I lost my aunt
and my father to cancer when I was kind
of ending high school and my grandmother
had a stroke. All that kind of just
made me look at life differently.
I stopped looking at life as about just
saving up for retirement and four one ks
and Roth Iras and
structure and I was like,
I'm going to hustle the seeds of all that.
We're um,
that I was an entrepreneur and
an artist or like living there.
Yeah.
If a crystal ball could tell you
the truth about yourself, your life,
the future or anything else,
what would you want
to know? Something I've been
thinking about a lot recently,
especially with that friendship question
is like what is the family that I'm
going to end up with? Not too
long ago, my grandpa passed away.
The one thing that I remember one
of my family members saying was, um,
he was really lucky to have his entire
family in the area to be with him as he
passed.
And that just got me thinking,
who are the family members that are going
to be with me at the end of my life?
Um, who are the friends I consider
my friends family as well. So
what you said about your Grandpa,
I mean that's, that's 100% true.
When my dad was sick and my sisters
and I took care of him and you know,
that was something that
every day it was like,
it was almost like a song he would sing.
He was just so grateful that we were all
there and we were like, well, of course.
Once you've seen that, once you've
experienced it in some, to some degree,
you realize how important that is.
Alternate sharing something you consider
a positive characteristic of your
partner. Share a total of five items. Oh,
let's do it.
I want to go first.
Yeah,
I sense this sort of um,
compassion that you have really seems
like you care and that makes me trust you
even though I've just met you two,
I think.
I think you are brave for making a lot
of these choices you have in your life to
follow the career paths that,
that you want.
You're making these choices and you're
following your heart and it seems like
you have the willpower and the drive
to succeed. Three, you look great
for. I really just admire
that you are from this place.
You have that sort of glow and positive
energy that's represents Los Angeles and
California. Hello, our sweat
glow.
And um,
not many people relax me,
but you've very relaxing,
very calming.
You have this groundedness to you that
I just desire but we'll never ever be.
So I think that's such a gift.
I felt the same way about you honestly.
I'm not just like turning it around.
Like when you first walked out, I
was like, this guy seems so chill.
I'm gonna have to ensure that
all of my Walkin's or that
long one mile space
though. No. Yeah, it was,
oh,
I find you extremely warm,
which I think is not common,
especially now hearing your story,
you definitely seem extremely
driven and I think that's awesome.
You don't just think of your
goals here and like, okay,
I'm going to start a business
so I'm going to do it.
And you started a production company
and kind of to tie in with, uh,
the first point that I
made it seem very familiar.
Mm.
I find it fairly easy to open
up to you and you're very open,
which is, which is great. Yeah. Not
going to lie coming into this. Um,
I was pretty nervous. Yeah. You have
helped me realize. I'm glad you're here.
That's really cool.
The final task is without speaking,
stare into each other's eyes for
four minutes, for four minutes.
So, um, let's do it. Okay.
Hmm.
Michael is a very grounded,
empathetic,
and compassionate person.
He's a total feeler.
Looking at him, I would've said
he's fucking cool and dress well.
I want to get to know him so much more.
She's for sure kind of different from a
lot of the people I've met here in la.
Maybe I've grown accustomed to
community here and that's just kind
of what I expect everyone to be like.
He was just very different,
which I really liked.
Ooh,
I was so bizarre. Yeah. Really? Why?
Oh my God, I can feel the jet lag.
No. Oh No. For like a brief minute,
like everything got really
blurry except for your face.
I was just looking at a Monica
for now dean here and I'm glad you did
this and this inspired me to just have
more meaningful discussions with
people that I meet anywhere.
It was nice to kind of just open up to
someone you knew nothing about.
I would, I would definitely be
interested in a second thing, Michael.
I think he's gonna do
great things in life. Yeah,
for sure.
MMM.
Whether it's as friends
explore something further.
This is actually kind of an amazing
experience to be flying in and meeting you
right away. You're being like kind of
welcome. It's cool. Michael, welcome.
Hi, I'm Dan. Hi,
I'm Taylor and thank you
so much for watching this
episode of tea for two and we
hope you enjoyed it.
Let us know what you think in the comments
and also click below for the link to
possibly be in our next episode.
Thanks so much.
Okay.